you may not want to [ __ ] up but if your
instinct tells you to do whatever you do
do that because you know what
it it stifles your creativity to be able
to
say well i'm not going to do that
because maybe somebody won't like it and
judge it do the [ __ ] that you like and
not what people expect from you and i
think you'll be a success
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my
god
hey guys it's all about confidence when
it comes to sex am i right i'm using it
alone like right now hey but sometimes
stress can affect uh your performance
and ruin the fun bluetooth to the rescue
try bluetooth free when you use promo
code omg hi checkout and just pay five
dollars shipping check this out that's
bluechew.com
promo code
omghi to receive your first
month
absolutely free
support for the oh my god hi podcast is
brought to you in part by sofi cut
through the jargon and make investing
easier with sofi visit sofi.com omghi
to learn how you can win up to a
thousand dollars in stock when you open
an account that's
dot com sofi.com
omg hi
hey everybody producer grant here again
this is part two of a two-part episode
so if you're just tuning in now make
sure to go back watch listen to part one
that came out last week with trevor this
is the remainder of that really really
fun interview with george and him here
you go
in the
late 90s
i had a friend of mine we haven't spoken
a long time uh
but he called me the last angry chicano
and i said what does that mean he said
you're mad at everything and you and you
know what i was mad at everything and i
was going nowhere and then i took that
advice and i said am i mad at everything
and i was i was mad at everything and i
was more concerned about what everybody
else was doing than what i was doing and
then one new year's because new year's
to me man always meant a a chance to i
mean when you're not doing [ __ ] new
year's eve doesn't mean anything and
then i said to myself okay this year i'm
gonna start worrying less about people
and start worrying more about myself and
when i did that my life changed yeah
that's right and if i had been thinking
the same way i was thinking back then
he was right i was [ __ ] mad at people
i didn't know and i was mad at things i
didn't understand and how the [ __ ] can
anybody be successful if you're [ __ ]
mad at inanimate objects and yeah
emotions you're not in control of them
i'm just fortunate i'm just fortunate at
the point in time in my life right now
because see
uh
comedic podcasts any of this stuff
was never in my
you know never in my bucket list yeah
never in your forte yeah and all of a
sudden this came across
and i've established new friends friends
yeah and and
your friends over there the crime people
no no john bernay ramsay's dad
who else
matter of fact i was asking if i wanted
to go see john christopher hanson
chris hanson
bounces checks who else
his checks bounce the of chris hanson
yeah yeah i've heard uh i've heard what
have you heard about him he did somebody
what do you like
what do you watch i you're not i like uh
reality tv like i like like like 90 day
fiance you ever watch that yeah i love
just you watch that uh married at first
sight i've seen that i like storage wars
let me ask you a question what do you
think about because you're young
[Music]
what do you think of marriage at first
sight
have you watched my own first sight i
think it's
have you seen i mean gil so people i've
never seen people want to get married
but they don't care
who the person is yeah and they let two
therapists right decide who's right for
you
yeah
i i think it's great for viewership you
know but i i in my right
they're like that's not my car they're
doing it for the cameras the second you
know what time they picked up they took
the car and they sold the four inch tvs
from the bumper
they're like we're done with this [ __ ]
yeah what he's saying it's like
ready yeah it's like a week later
a week later no more [ __ ]
if you're not on the show no more
[ __ ] i'll get some money back eh yeah
dude all right you know that is that
awesome or not
what about the ultimatum where a girl
it's usually a girl that takes a dude in
there but a dude never takes a girl in
there and say marry me or else
the hell do you see the ultimatum on
netflix uh-uh the ultimatum on netflix
is you don't even have to watch it to
understand this it's that
the the the
i think it's more of the woman
takes their fiance
to this show and there's like eight
couples there and they say marry me or
else but also in this group of eight
people there might be somebody that's
with someone else that you might connect
to oh wow yo man i mean that's i mean we
had a version like that on mtv called
parental control if you ever saw that
yeah remember that they would be like
our our daughter is dating a piece of
[ __ ] so now we're gonna have auditions
for people in town that can date her
they would pick like one guy the big
this is that what parental control is
yeah and then the dude [ __ ] did i not
watch that show oh it's it's it's hello
do you ever watch that [ __ ] no i've
never seen the best show ever i would
hate it because my mother-in-law
hated me really exactly oh she hates me
so for example they would have had
hundreds of dudes meet up at a warehouse
in downtown l.a get the [ __ ] out and
then they would all audition for the
paper wait a minute is birth control
still active this was like this was like
maybe like
2000
yeah 2006 yeah
wait a minute how come that show's not
still on they they set them up for every
every show dude then what it gets worse
they would find a guy right
but because the piece of [ __ ] boyfriend
and then the
girlfriend's parents would watch them go
on a live date he would be watching the
tv show oh my god he would be seeing his
girlfriend go on a date with another man
and then he would always be like he
won't kiss her
no he'd be like she's not going to kiss
him she loves me she's loyal and then
she would kiss the new dude on tv and
the guy would just be there like man oh
[ __ ] this i'm out i don't even care and
then she got to pick between going back
with the boyfriend or the new man oh
this dude is still there
wait a minute
why isn't the show
still on
because people
oh my god hey wait a minute
that whatever netflix is doing th this
[ __ ] is dude they were ahead of all
their shows wrapped up that sounds that
that sounds like what i went through
with my wife really yeah i thought so
tell him because i had a dear john when
i was in vietnam oh okay he went to
vietnam
what's the dear john that's a letter
hang on a second oh i don't know what it
is you don't know what a dear gentleman
millennial man i don't know a lot of
things man so i i at
seven
i turned 18 november 29th february first
in 19
uh
they didn't have numbers there they just
put dirt on
a pile of dirt yeah yeah 90s on a wall
67
67 i turned 18
on november 29th
two months later i'm in vietnam in war
in combat so damn how about that [ __ ]
man and that and that's because at 17
the cops took me down the light bulb
[Laughter]
cops took me home and told my parents
signed them to get off the streets or
we'll end up dead or in prison so they
signed i went
went to combat come back
now it's three years later i'm out of
the army
i wanted to go to college because at
that point in time now i had a new
appreciation on life
i was mature i knew i was mature because
what i said for my
high school transcripts i thought d
stood for i was embarrassed i obviously
thought d stood for damn good that was
fabulous oh yeah but they let me into
community college because i had been to
combat because i've been in vietnam wow
i wanted to become a cop
i wanted to give back what that cop gave
to me and that was new lease on life
third thing was i wanted to start dating
my ex-girlfriend who wrote me a a dear
john that's a letter you get when you're
in combat that says
sorry i don't love you anymore it's a
yeah you're aware and i'm here and i've
got somebody else wow so my heart was
broken yeah all right let me ask this
what's the number again uh 818 533 all
right if anybody has ever broken up with
anybody by text message
call that number
and ask us why you did it or tell us why
you did it and what you thought you
would accomplish and it was right
to face like people people text people
hey [ __ ] you i'm not going to come we
didn't have texts then
the idea of somebody bringing her
over
because she knew when she sent that
letter
that he was going to get it and that he
would be [ __ ] heartbroken i mean that
letter had to come from l.a
and go to vietnam yeah
and he was going to get that and guys
were happy to get letters so do you
remember when they say uh i got a letter
from home oh god damn carrillo you're
like hey i got a letter did you send a
letter back like [ __ ] you no i no i
didn't i mean when i got out of the army
the third goal i had in life was to get
her eaten out of them i want to hook up
with her there you go get her eaten out
of the palm of my hand so i could break
it off in her right oh you wanted to
totally
i wanted repairs
hey so you go over there you have
flowers a limo you're like oh you never
did this before and then you end the
break
so you got back with her i got out in
june of 70 september of 70 and eating
out of the palm of my hand
the day after christmas
oh we got married
we got married and i just we just had
our 51st wedding anniversary are you
still with us
yeah congratulations i thought you said
the day after christmas you broke her
heart
we got married
well i said you should have done it yeah
if you're gonna break up though you
gotta do it on the 24th so you don't
gotta get her a christmas present
yeah but you know what he thought he was
gonna he thought he would be able to
tell her you know what i don't want to
be with you anymore i just got you back
so i could tell you but then you married
her right yeah well the reality is i
couldn't deny her i was a good catch
yeah i mean the i think life works in a
weird way like that you know i met my
current girlfriend in 2017 but we didn't
start dating until like you know three
years down the road we would kind of
talk off and on off and on she had other
partners i don't know hang on a second
you're going too fast where did you meet
her instagram like a real
piece of [ __ ] what i'm saying
like
but but tell me how you saw her
you saw you you said the dm you sliding
the dm yeah yeah so i feel like you guys
are going to hear this and just be like
i hate this generation wait a minute
because there's an art too and i feel
like you know you you know
there's an art to it i know i i do it
because
instagram can be a creepy place or a
wonderful place you know so what
happened is in 2017 i had some videos
start to get some good views but i
didn't have a lot of followers so if i
saw my notifications i could see like
who was liking stuff and i saw this girl
she liked the photo and i could tell by
her profile photo that she was cute and
i was like all right so i click it and
it says that she went to usc and i was
living in uh santa monica at the time
she was at usc so i this is where it
gets the art form so i go in and i like
a photo of hers just to let her know
tap on the glass let the fish know that
i'm tapping you know on the glass yeah
and then she comes back and this is
this is where and i think you can
co-sign this this is where you know that
she was down she went back on my page
and she liked three photos now we're
doing this morris code type thing
absolutely that opens up the morning
yeah yeah so that opens up the
floodgates then i shoot the dm and the
dm was something stupid i think it was
just it was an emoji which is just like
a hand wave or something like that yeah
and then that was like oh hey
you know love the videos then now we're
now we're in
and uh we ended up getting drinks in
santa monica a couple weeks but how did
that how did that you say hey would you
like to meet up
and have a get a drink or something yeah
i think it's pretty straight forward um
she but also you know you she trusted
you yeah she knew you were at a profile
yeah i mean a guy named trevor you know
it's like that's a pretty safe bet i
trust you already yeah you know so
um but people think a guy named trader
might be of an alternate lifestyle but
true i've also had a girl
show up to my house
and she pulled a knife out of her bra 30
minutes after talking oh she was bored
no no no no no
no this is she pulls it out of her bra
we're just talking the couch pulls out
and puts on the table she goes i can
trust you
i brought this just in case you never
know but i just wanted to put it out how
about that [ __ ] that that she
had a knife with a bra in case she made
a move on her she would just be like
that make sure that nipple wasn't cut
that's i think
you know it's like you're going to a
man's house you've never met him you
only talked online you know what man
you're right but it's but it is wild
because i opened the door in moccasins i
was wearing moccasins on my feet i was
like you really think a guy in moccasins
is a threat a guy demarcus is isn't
going anywhere fast yeah exactly slip
out of that thing but it was like and
then they're hot you get the dna out
there [ __ ] but it was weird
because at one point i was like what the
[ __ ] i'm i'm appalled you would think me
that way but on the other point i was
like oh dang so she's down you know so
so it was both
both passed but
and in that in that uh relationship do
you think that this person is the one
like like you guys are vibing currently
yeah yeah yeah i really love this one oh
yeah but i think
when you go to the next room
yeah i think it's in the same way that
you you said it just felt right you know
yeah it did something like that so how
do you feel what is her background
she's in finance so so she does like tax
stuff and she does a bunch of like stock
trading and does she understand the
world that you that you want to live in
she's
or potentially the world that you might
you know yeah we're figuring out as you
as you go
as you aspire i do what is your
aspirations do you want to be
you want to you want to get your own
television show would you like to do
movies you want to do i think all that
would be great i think yeah everything
you know i think i love what i do right
now but i also want to just like amplify
and do tv show or movies and shoot a
special you know i'd love to shoot a
special on this uh theater tour right
now and at the end of it i do want to
shoot something whether it goes to a
streaming platform or just youtube i
don't really care okay i just want to do
this all right can i tell you this okay
if you would allow me to please i would
love to produce one of your special
really yeah that'd be awesome man so you
and i would go to some place that you
you think that you'd want to go on and
we would walk in there and i'd say you
know what i like the way this guy thinks
and gill and i are going to produce your
special that'd be awesome man
whether it's netflix you know walk into
netflix wherever you want to go yeah
that'd be awesome man yeah i mean it's
you're kidding me because i like i like
the vibe that you have i like the vibe
that you have
and
you know i uh
myself you know i've had a few successes
yeah
you could walk into netflix and just
sell them a video of you taking a piss
and they'd be like it's awesome but i
want you to be happy with where you go
and i want you to be able to be able to
do what you do thanks man that means a
lot and also
as myself i would love to produce i mean
one of the reasons i think i'm i'm not
sure
why we started this but i think if you
see somebody like
like you
that right gayle of all that's right
we've had a lot of people they've been
great but i love
the extra little bit of care about what
you are and what you do thanks man that
reminds me of myself i'm not gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] you reminds me yeah man
are you talking about your stories about
you being 18 and you seeing richard
pryor not going up to him and just
you're like you know he's working you're
acknowledging you've been in the game
for a long time
for a long time so you saw what it was
like to be
when nobody makes eye contact with you
now you get a little bit of a buzz now
people are saying what's up to you at
the club and now you're you're a
sensation you're everywhere you're
global i'm auditioning for a bunch of
stuff but i think it's like uh
you know maybe it's not the right place
let me tell you something man
i
auditioned for a comedian on murphy
brown
in the 90s bobby collins got it and
it's funny and the only thing that i
ever got
auditioning
after
[ __ ] over 20 years was my show wow
that's but but
how thankful are you that that let out
you know maybe because what if you
booked something right before that
just because you get a deal to do a show
doesn't mean it's going to be successful
i don't want to believe it i watch the
credits on air and that's that's what i
think that you have i think you have the
ability to dig in
when when people dig in and also you
know even watching jerry seinfeld
comedian it's like you know that guy
you know somebody told me
you're going to hear [ __ ] you don't like
and you're going to want to leave but
stay in the room because when you leave
you leave yeah
that's true and
and
i was upset one time on my show that the
first show that
i got in my car and i started my car
and i thought if i leave
i'm leaving the show's named after me
i'm leaving over somebody who's in that
stage and i turn my car off went back in
the room and handled it damn but and
what somebody hadn't told me
when if you don't like something that
you hear
[Music]
don't leave yeah because it's ebb and
flow man everything's a ebb and flow
yeah you're not not everything that
everybody tells you is going to be
something you're going to want to hear
right so don't be like hey [ __ ] this
[ __ ] and you leave and everybody looks
like you're like well i guess we need to
find another guy right
stay in there that's the hardest part
and that's why i was so mad when the guy
gave me those notes at the comedy club
he was like it's funny but it's not you
and i was like yeah what do you know and
then
you you learn to take criticism and then
when you think about it and put it to
you
and that criticism you put it to you as
you
saying you know what
maybe
i do need to be more focused on this and
that if if dave becky had to give me
that that
constructive criticism out of caroline's
at that time in like 92 93 i'm not sure
we'd be here right now crazy yeah i
think all those the little random things
was like milestones along the way you
can't predict them whether it's like
whether you got inspired from dave back
here i got inspired from a guy down the
street at a comic
i don't think he club
him to jack off every time he saw a
woman but i don't know
he should have i mean now what a grammy
he wanted
you know
acceptance speech
fired one off right there yeah he's got
quite the roster out there of a man ck
too mad like you know um
hey man
you know comedians and actors and
actresses and people who hold high
positions have always been a
questionable character
and sometimes that was accepted usually
but then with social media it became a
thing where you could hold yourself and
judge somebody else's character that
usually remained behind covers right i
mean don't think actresses or or greta
garbo does my [ __ ] sunset strip about
the actress that sat in the room that
looked at herself
that's all in the public now like nobody
can be a freak oh and be in your house
and be a freak everything's exposed
everybody was afraid back then yeah and
and everybody was a freak back then
and they
earned the right to be a freak but now
you'll see somebody with 12 followers
that'll become a freak that doesn't
deserve to be a freak as far as i think
yeah i don't think you have enough
followers i mean it's like everything
with johnny depp right now can i be a
freak yes am i a freak you already are
girl you're a freak
like johnny depp yeah but you never
think about him like that you just think
about his movie roles and now all these
trials are coming out and you're like
what the hell it's like yeah he's been
doing this he shouldn't be doing that
yeah and you know what if you fall
asleep [ __ ] passed out in your house
drugged out it's your [ __ ] house
i fell asleep in a casino
[ __ ] years ago drunk as a
[ __ ]
but did you win money that night
i i couldn't get to the
oh you didn't even make it to gambling
when i saw the picture
when the police came to me i said how'd
the police get in my room i didn't know
where i was damn but but again
it was not in a place of of
like a home depot or a whole foods it it
was where it deserved to be i felt like
a casino i was [ __ ] up passing out at
home depot it was funny that's
like i tried to listen to you
or fall asleep in a rite aid
getting ice cream with your [ __ ] car
turned on
but you know i i fell asleep in a casino
people drinking a casino i was in there
i was drinking a casino and but but it's
like but it's like it's like what people
look at as
uh a portable behavior really isn't
really isn't
at all
hey guys it's all about confidence when
it comes to sex am i right sometimes
stress anxiety or a bad day or just
maybe uh your age can affect your
performance and ruin the fun for both of
you but guess what bluetooth.com to the
rescue bluetooth is a unique online
thirst that has the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable form at a fraction of the cost
so check this out so you know as you get
older sometimes it's low testosterone
there's a million things that cause you
to not perform at the highest level
possible that's why i think for me
personally i'm happy bluetooth came
along because it's chewable and then
you're doable that's my slogan for it
you're too it's chewable and you become
doable and here's a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use the promo code omghi
at checkout and that's just five dollars
for shipping so that's bluechew.com
promo code
omghi to receive your first month free
remember bluetooth tablets are chewable
and then that makes you
doable
investing can be very confusing these
days there's terms getting thrown around
like meme stocks altcoin shilling all
sorts of crazy stuff and with that
jargon flying around it can be hard to
figure out how to start investing
thankfully we have so far and getting
your money right is easier than ever
with sofi it's the first investing
platform to offer stocks etfs automated
investing and cryptocurrency too and
this is all in one app we're all users
of sofi here at omg high and i love the
user experience personally very easy to
navigate very simple puts everything in
one place you know when it comes to
money you don't want there to be any
questions you want there any confusion
and and with sofi
it's a it's a beautiful thing you'll
have none of that stuff you'll have a
good time
so whether you're eager to get started
with investing or you already know the
ropes and you want to diversify your
portfolio so fi has your back there's no
commissions that's on stocks and etfs no
account fees no hidden fees none of that
stuff that just kind of sucks frankly
and they have complementary financial
planners who are on hand and ready to
help you with any questions whether
you're stuck on where to start or need
help on deciding what to do next sofi
has got your back you can even save for
retirements uh you know if we're all
able to do that someday with traditional
roth and sep
iras so cut through the jargon and make
investing easier with sofi visit
sofi.com omghi and learn how you can win
up to 1 000
in stock when you open an account that's
sofi.com
omg hi
brokerage and active investing products
offered through sofi securities llc
member finra sipc
i mean those people that [ __ ] up and
just
like just people who you know in their
town might be so i'm going to tell you
something
you you may not want to [ __ ] up but if
your instinct tells you to do whatever
you do do that because you know what
it it stifles your creativity to be able
to
say well i'm not going to do that
because maybe somebody won't like it and
judge it do the [ __ ] that you like and
not what people expect from you and i
think you'll be a success right i think
it's just listening to your own
instincts that's right that's what it is
right gil that's right you have to worry
about what [ __ ] people think about
you oh they're not going to like if i do
this [ __ ] that i'll never forget an
acting teacher and she
i was a school
uh
i think so i think so yeah
yeah that's the first time your
assistant had a smile on her face
i always asked on the show
big titties yeah yeah yeah my mom also
had a rack but anyways
thank you
but she
moved she was living in l.a when in her
20s and then she moved back and she was
teaching i went to san jose state and
she was teaching like theater stuff and
she was like i wish when i lived in los
angeles i didn't give a [ __ ] what people
thought because now i'm in my 50s and i
have all these regrets because i thought
all these people would care and it was a
real moment i saw like pain in her eyes
and i'll never forget that moment
because i was like she
she cared so much about what the other
people in los angeles were thinking and
the other opinions of her they let her
eat her way and now she's
you know she's you know what wasted
years that is exactly right
when i was in uh 12th grade back in
did you have big titties yes
i had a couple of nubs
that would potentially be big that us
hey let's go and uh uh when they asked
us to put
you know people have vision boards now
oh yeah
they we had a notebook like a mead
notebook and they said cut pictures out
of the magazine
and put the things on the mag like a
collage of the things that you like
and on that was kiss
i'm friends with the guys and kiss nice
freddy prinz i got freddy prinze's star
in the walk of fame
uh uh ted nugent ted nugent and our
friends
um a tr uh a fiat tr3 which
i i think i got a better card than that
but but the thing is fourth grade you
wanted a fiat in 12th grade they had
fiats back then back to the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i thought they were like
like i thought they're out there with
like mini cooper
yeah am i thinking about this
that's a little wind up one way before
the mini cooper wasn't even a [ __ ] that
wasn't even a [ __ ] cooper to make
them
but everything that i put on my on my
12th grade
thing
happened to me wow
see i like stuff like that i have a
photo of uh from like 2017 i wrote on a
whiteboard it's like all my goals for
like i want a video to hit a million
views i want to get a headlining set i
want to go on the road for three
weekends i want to you know get this
many followers on this social media and
i look back on i was like damn like you
know it's like
you might not think about it every day
but at one point you put it down there
and then you just keep working towards
it but you know what man nobody has this
[ __ ] worth like ethic anymore
nobody nobody has come in here and said
what he has said not even me it's it's
so nice to see it's refreshing
and see what you're doing thanks man but
because so many people don't go but also
it's goals yeah goals but also you have
a determination yeah and goals are going
listen perseverance
if somebody says you know i remember
when i turned 40 i looked in the mirror
and and if somebody says you know i
wanna
uh uh be
what i say the biggest start it's like
there's goals and there's dreams
yeah a dream is if you wanted to to
[ __ ] fly
that's that's a dream
but if you want to be a comedian have
your own show and do specials and travel
around
the world and do stand-up
that's a goal yeah it's not a dream yeah
and that's what i learned about anything
when i turned 40. yeah and when i turned
42
i
had my own show
on stage four warner brothers where they
had done murphy brown for the previous
10 years and then i was there for
[ __ ] six years yeah and i'm a
household name when i didn't even like
my name when i was in my own household
so i would say to you as i said
you my friend have
a vibe that i think people would
understand thank you you should do your
thing and we're going to produce your
special wherever you want it to be i
would love to you cutting this off all
right no oh what
did you have microphone though
yeah there we go that excites me here we
go just got his big break too and bring
him in what did you do what would you do
if you had to do a special what would
you do it i would do it in either san
diego or arizona don't tell me where in
san diego and tell me where in arizona
i'm not sure the venue but
but though the energy out there is
unmatched so where though at uh at uh
theater in san diego i've already done
comedy clubs in both those i'm doing a
theater there uh no you're not gonna do
yours we're not gonna do your special in
a [ __ ] comedy club no no i'm just
saying the energy that they give out in
those cities has been phenomenal but um
i would either do that or i love the
theater and uh tampa florida i did the
tampa theater it was phenomenal
it was like there's like a 100 1100 i
think you should do it there i'd do it
it would the other one on the water yeah
right there the energy there was
insane in florida they don't give a [ __ ]
they're just excited yeah and also they
don't give a [ __ ] they are excited yeah
i like that they're genuinely excited
that like a fun act is in their town you
know you shoot something in like new
york or los angeles like there's so much
going on you're kind of numb to like
what a cool event is you know it's it's
like right up the street the dave
chappelle shows at the hollywood bowl
it's like yeah the night before i was at
a club for 100 people you know it's like
there's so much going on in the city but
when you go to a place like tampa or
like st louis you're the thing of the
night you're the guy in town so this is
it's a different excitement you know so
i'll probably do that um
but yeah i'd say one of those too for
sure and how would you dress if you if
you when you when we do this how how
what were you wearing
i uh i like to wear plain clothes
because i don't want people to judge
anything or i don't want people trying
to read in my shirt when i'm up there
you know i just want people to be like
this
i don't want to i don't know
uh you know what in in the uh 80s when i
was working during the day they did a
story on me and at my job at teledine in
northridge and i was wearing a detroit
tigers polo shirt that i got in l.a and
this guy that had been
a relative of valentine the magician
member balancing and he said he said to
me
always dress better than the people that
come to see you that's smart
and
i you know i've always worn suits in all
of my black suits and all my yeah
oh yeah and uh you know what that was
advice that he goes if a guy is taking a
girl on a date and they're coming to see
you
should they be dressed better than you
and i would be like no yeah
classy nike so you should look you
should look presentable as opposed to
somebody wearing a hawaiian shirt or
shorts
oh
i i think i know somebody who happens to
do yeah
i mean were you are you at a [ __ ]
luau or you had a [ __ ] show yeah no i
mean yeah uh i'm right that's why i
don't wear like a hoodie on stage some
some as small as that but like a nice
crew neck i might even iron it if i like
the city enough you know
as long as you look presentable yeah do
you mind people come and see you and
they go
is that the guy on stage or is that
somebody that's going to help us
move our car in case they don't start
yeah no i feel that too you know i just
never want to be too flashy because
there's nothing worse than dressing
flashy than bombing no no no but
flashy's like flashing like bright
colors and stuff right but right
you're prepared so you as you go you'll
find out what's what's right for you oh
yeah i like just i'd probably wear what
i'm wearing right now crew neck some
pants white shoes let me see what yo
what's he wearing name you wearing white
shoes
yeah
yeah
yeah
you know i couldn't figure out where his
sock ended and his legs started oh yeah
looked like he put that leg up there put
your leg up there with a sock this
motherboard is white look look at that
yeah
it went from those socks
hey so what does your mom think can she
come and see you perform yeah they'll be
there uh i'm doing the novo in downtown
yeah tell us where you're at in two
weeks
uh the novo in downtown that's the last
uh stop on the tour that's may 20th and
what's up
the argue that guy tour it's just kind
of like a lot of you know i got a lot of
uh i think i have a good recognition of
my face online but not everybody knows
my name so in public when people say
stuff they're like yeah are you that guy
you're that guy and my friends will joke
about me if we're at a bar we're just
like drinking whatever and some guys are
like yo are you that guy and then when
that guy leaves all my friends
so now it's like this like funny uh kind
of story and it's like this tour was
really me breaking out into like the
world be like no i really do this this
stand up i really do this comedy stuff
instead of like you know a lot of people
know me for the video stuff but you know
i've been doing stand up longer than
i've been doing videos so okay so so so
have you thought about
uh if you walk into a place and
everybody knows you have you have you
said to yourself man what would it be
like to walk into a place and everybody
knows you have you thought about that
yeah i mean it it's wild because you
know you got to take a step back
sometimes you're like oh this is
annoying you're like is it annoying or
is it cool
you know sometimes
let me tell you from someone who
walks into a place pretty much anywhere
i've traveled to europe
and people know who they are
it's a pain in the ass it it there's
times i love it then there's times that
like 6 a.m at the airport and i want to
tell you
that one time i was at the [ __ ]
airport
and then one of these people were
looking at me
and i was with brian and i said is this
[ __ ] gonna ask me to take a
picture with him at 5 30 in the morning
oh yeah and and they walk over and
you've had no sleep and still drunk and
they said hey can we take a picture with
you and you're like yeah yeah let's do
it
but
you haven't experienced what i've
experienced yet i hope that you do
but it is a pin the ass to go
everywhere you go yeah and have somebody
recognize you i don't care where it is
you go to a [ __ ]
donut shop at 6 30 in vancouver or you
go to
a uh uh
i mean you're global i had it i had a
store in new york
i just received a
text uh photograph
i don't know where you were in some
airport with a friend of mine with
george uh
the buddy of mine you ran oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and
here he is i'm in one airport and i'm
getting a picture from george another
guy at the other airport
uh
george oh look too happy it's a blessing
and a curse
uh no i think it's just a question
blessing it's a blessing
it's not a curse
it's an inconvenience okay i wouldn't
say it's a curse not a curse i don't
know why you know because your life
because as people recognize you as you
have good fortune in this business that
you are allowed
things that uh you know that that
people who who don't
don't have
you know i've been a member i've played
golf since 1981 i'm a member at this
country club that is not far from where
i live i've been a member there since
2004 and i'm going there after we we
leave here and and i don't have to wait
in line and all that other stuff but so
so
i would say that i would wish for you
the problems that i've had yeah because
i think you would enjoy them oh yeah
there's some great ones you know
sometimes like you recognize that like
an in-n-out and i'm like so we getting
free fries today like i can't do that
but i'm like you know what that's good
humble me
i've been at disneyland and the people
working there are like oh you don't have
a fast pass oh you're trevor wallace go
right away and i'm like
there it is
there's the upside down everything but
have you been to a place where they give
you a car
no
you got a free ass car
look i only got one man how many cars
you got how many cars you got
how many cars do i have yeah it's not
how many cars i have oh that's a lot
yeah it's if you got to give me
something
yeah i've had a house in hawaii about a
house oh man that's a gorgeous what
island mexico and lanai oh it's gorgeous
but
but
then i've uh you know i'm still right
here with gil yeah that's right man i'll
take it doesn't make you it does
i'm just saying i wish you the
opportunities of that right
thanks man yeah yeah i mean
and i think and i think that
and i think that and i feel that you
know it's like somebody when you give
somebody advice and you go i don't know
if they're going to take that device i
feel like i feel like i didn't even have
to we didn't even have to say anything
about that about it's like you're on
that path already i think the biggest
advice is just trust your gut
continually keep on going you said you
got the show at 42 and it's like but you
got in 18 you know there's a long time
of just like patience and and doubling
down just betting on yourself and
keeping your head down like that's the
more advice i ever need you know man i i
had quitted everything in my life you
know my baseball coach told me
in 12th grade you're a [ __ ] quitter
and you know what he did he have good
tits
he's got a good memory
he was in good shape yeah but who else
had to be what good that does my
girlfriend high school did hey
and uh
when he when he reminded i mean these
are all the things that
the the universe puts in place
like the universe put him in my place to
remind me
or to let me know
that
even if i didn't know i was a quitter i
was a quitter
and if he had not told me that i'm not
again i'm not sure
what would have happened to me yeah
because i was a [ __ ] quitter and he
was a hundred percent right it was
almost like if somebody would stand in
front of you that you respected
and they would just dress you down
and hopefully that you would be able to
take that advice instead of saying
[ __ ] him and just check out completely i
understood what he told me
maybe i didn't get it but when i started
playing golf and i quit when it got hard
i understood it yeah so the two things
connected
but without without that i'm not here
without that i don't live where i live
or without that i'm not taking care of
the people that i'm taking care of but
i'm saying that that in a time when
social media
is
maybe the place that people
become the more identifiable
it's like the people who
take the time to
to to look at
the [ __ ] reality of who they are
is like those are the people that
succeed not to say oh i'm not tick doc i
have all this but what is it in you that
makes you that person right
that's what it is it's not checking your
followers and go hey i got 10 more
followers today it's like what's in you
that is not for them but is only for you
by the foundation that's what i'm saying
you know i think that's a good place to
stop right there yeah i'm great i'm
appreciative you guys have me on right
this is awesome
i love this dude man yeah
good job well i appreciate you guys for
having me good and we'll talk uh soon
and and we'll get we're gonna we're
gonna do this special yeah you tell you
tell this is that's what i'm gonna say
and where he's gonna come back when we
do it yeah you i'm gonna give you my
information and you tell me and you tell
us
where you wanna do your special and when
you wanna do your special and you and i
and all of us will go and contact those
places
and take the meeting and they will tell
us yes or no yeah but i'll be in that
room with you when you pitch your
special i love it man
i'm great for that yeah i love it i love
this guy this guy's [ __ ] smarter he
reminds me of myself yeah i appreciate
it man with a bigger nose but you're on
my nose
my nose is this way but you know we put
two and two together we have to pitch
two specials
together we have eleven yeah no i trust
me
but you know what man i love i love
i i love that
i mean it's just an energy that
is immediate like the minute you speak a
word you can feel it thanks man i
appreciate it this is awesome i mean
that it's uh as opposed to gil that
[ __ ] been there
i appreciate you guys for having me this
is fun oh it's a good time
let's do it
let's do it man
let's do it
you